we need to figure out what ninety-nine
point zero six 1 divided by a hundred is
so we are figuring out what ninety-nine
point zero six 1 divided by divided by
100 so in this situation our divisor is
already a whole number so we don't have
to do any of that multiplying by a ten
or a hundred to move the decimal over to
the right it's already a whole number so
we're ready to divide but the first
thing we want to do in this just to make
sure we don't make any mistakes
is make sure we put the decimal in the
right place so the decimal is going to
sit right over here this is where it was
sitting before so this is where it will
sit in our quotient and now we are ready
to divide so the first thing we want to
say is well does hundred go into nine
well no it doesn't so does 100 go into
99 no it doesn't and if we want we could
put a zero here but we could just keep
going we'll add the zero at the end so
one hundred doesn't go into nine it
doesn't go into 99 there's a hundred go
into nine hundred and ninety does it go
into nine hundred and ninety sure it'll
go nine times it goes into nine hundred
ninety-nine times so that's why we put
the nine above the zero because we had
to get all the way to the zero for the
hundred to be divisible into the number
hundred goes into nine hundred
ninety-nine times nine times 100 is nine
hundred and then we can subtract so nine
hundred ninety minus nine hundred is
ninety we could do that in our heads you
could say zero minus zero zero nine
minus 0 is 9 these guys cancel out now
we can bring down we can bring down this
six a hundred goes into 906 that's nine
times nine times 100 is nine hundred and
then we can subtract nine hundred and
six minus nine hundred is going to be
six and then we bring down the 1 we can
bring down that one we bring down that
one a hundred goes into sixty-one it
doesn't it goes into it zero times it
goes into it zero times zero times 100
is zero and then when you subtract you
have a remainder of 61 now you might be
tempted
say okay it goes into it is well we
could always put a leading zero here a
zero point nine nine zero times with a
remainder of sixty one but whenever you
do first of all what network that's not
write the remainder isn't a sixty one
because we're now in the decimal kind of
work to the right of the decimal point
but in general whenever you're dividing
two decimals you want to keep dividing
you don't want to have a remainder and
the best way to keep dividing is to
remember that this has as many trailing
zeros on it as you want they're not
really changing the number so we can
throw a bunch of zeros to the right of
here as many as we need so let's throw a
zero right now
bring it down let's throw that zero
bring it down a hundred goes into 610
six times six times six times 100 is 600
and then we subtract 600 ten minus 600
is ten we don't want to have a remainder
so we keep going so let's throw let's
throw another zero here and bring it
down and bring it down so we have
another zero there a hundred goes into a
hundred exactly one time exactly one
time one times 100 is 100 and then now
when you subtract we have no remainder
and we are satisfied and we're done and
sometimes you're gonna see that you're
gonna have to keep doing it you're gonna
start having repeated numbers up here
and strange things up here and there's
other ways we'll deal with that but in
most it were in this circumstance you
just want to keep going you want to keep
going until you have no remainder so our
final answer is 99 divided by zero 99
sorry ninety-nine point zero six one
divided by a hundred is equal to is
equal to zero point nine nine zero six
one and I just put a leading zero here
just sometimes it makes it easier to
read and you make sure people understand
that there's a decimal there it just
makes it a less prone to errors and we
are done and just to make the point this
actually makes sense
ninety-nine is a little bit less than
100 so 99 divided by 100 is going to be
a little bit less than one and this
number is a little bit less than one